I've talked before about the mind virus, that is.
ISM and I've talked about the very real impact
that watching Fox News and listening to Trump has
on people, an Economist YouGov poll finds that
86 percent of Trump voters believe Joe Biden has
not legitimately won the election. 86 percent of
Trump voters fell for the Trump voter fraud scam,
which, according to reports we got yesterday,
Trump doesn't even really believe and is using
just to pay off campaign debt. Trump built
this up for months, saying it will be rigged.
Voter fraud is for a voter, a vote by mail is
fraudulent, etc. And it worked in a Washington
Post poll. More than 75 percent of Trump voters
believe Trump should not concede. So Trump
does have the support of his base to continue.
Not conceding, which is a reminder is merely a
formality. Concession is not legally relevant.
Now, even more interesting is that when asked
whether Trump should contest the results of
the election in court, about 85 percent of Trump
is believed Trump should go to court. Remember,
the latest is Trump doesn't even think it will
work. And when asked whether it will work to
change the election results in hand trump a
victory. Trump ists are marginally more realistic,
but 60 percent of Trump voters believe what
Trump is doing will get him a second term. I
really need you to understand that what we are
seeing right now, even though Joe Biden is moving
forward with appointments and his transition team,
a coronavirus task force, the election is over.
Foreign leaders are calling Joe Biden. They're
already setting up transition with Joe Biden.
More than half of Trump voters expect that Donald
Trump will be inaugurated to a second term on
January 20th. This is a mind virus. Donald
Trump succeeded not in winning the election,
but in using months of rhetoric about mail
in ballot fraud and rigged elections to
convince most of his supporters that it was
rigged and that Joe Biden didn't really win.
But then we really need to get to the next part,
which I mentioned earlier this week. If you watch
Fox News at night, every anchor is saying this
stuff. It was stolen, there was fraud, illegal
votes, illegal ballots. If you only get your news
from Fox News and you look at Trump's Twitter,
why would you think anything else there go to
news? Sources are telling them exactly that. And
86 percent of Trump voters fell for it, 86 percent
of Trump voters is more than 60 million people.
60 million people think Joe Biden didn't really
win. These are doctors, your kids, teachers,
accountants, waiters, truck drivers. You don't
get 60 million from unemployed basement dwelling
al-Qaida, if you understand what I'm saying.
Now, if you went and you interviewed some of
these 60 million and you asked them, oh, OK, you
think Trump actually won, by the way, why did you
vote for Trump? What first term successes are you
most proud of? What issues did you care about?
Their answers will make no sense. And then you'll
have a better understanding of how 86 percent fell
for this voter fraud storyline. But I want to
go back to where we started the week on Monday.
As ignorant as they may be, as
unsympathetic as they may be,
whatever you want to say about these people,
whatever you want to believe about these people,
they're 72 million of them, OK? Biden barely
won when it came to the margins in the key
three states that ultimately won this for
him. We have to do something about those
trumpet's. I don't yet know what the answer
is. And some people wrote to me saying,
you really should be presenting a solution. Well,
I don't have one yet. I'm being up front. I don't
know. This is a real problem. It's a mind virus.
OK, 72 million, 60 million believe that Trump
actually won. I don't yet know the answer, but
as soon as I have some ideas, I will come to you